add this to the list of problems
plaguing mayor Pete a government
Watchdog looking into the transportation
secretary's use of private jet after
taking more than 18 taxpayer-funded
flights since taking office secretary
budigence says he welcomes a review
the vast majority of the time I travel
on commercial airlines and economy class
but there is a portion of the time I'd
say about 10 to 20 percent when we use
our agency's aircraft this is not
chartering a private jet the number one
reason we would use that agency aircraft
is that it actually works out to be less
expensive for taxpayers
judge you seem to have a strong opinion
I think he makes a decent point but
we'll let the let the audit take place
yeah if he's telling the truth let the
audit take place but I don't understand
how uh he usually flies economy on a
commercial flight but when he uses the
agency's aircraft it's in it where it
saves taxpayers money how is the
agency's airplane cheaper to fly than an
economy class C but let me just say this
about Buddha judge and I'll be very
quick the guy was offline for the first
four weeks uh that he was Secretary of
Transportation he took two months off of
paternity leave now he's he doesn't show
up for things that are his job and he
doesn't have any experience in the area
and now we got to worry about how we're
spending our money let the guy go that's
the end of it Jesse so this is the Biden
response to an investigation it was
consensual I welcome I welcome the audit
audit me all you want this is good I'm
going to take a artificial position
I want mayor Pete on a private jet and I
don't mind if mayor Pete's Sitting In
First Class because if I'm in coach and
I see the Secretary of Transportation
say excuse me and then shimmy his little
body across my seat and sit next to me
and put his tray down
that's pathetic I mean this guy's got
work to do he's working for us get the
guy comfortable give him some room to
space out his papers feed them something
to get his blood sugar up and then get
him on to his next location that's a
pretty darn good artificial stance very
good and you know what we're wasting
money everywhere else what's another
first class ticket Dana so Fox digital
gets some credit here because they were
the only ones who were following this
and Americans Republic trust published
some of these schedules and the fox
digital took a look at it and they they
did like their own audit and they that
preceded what is now an official
investigation so uh you know other media
could have had that if they had wanted
to there's lots of stories out there but
if you can find there's all sorts of
agencies that you could be looking at
um but I so I give some credit to them I
also feel that mayor Pete must feel like
why'd I take this job why do I want this
job because I think his political
Ambitions are slowly dwindling right
before his eyes
I don't think he looks that look these
guys always fail up right I mean look at
Gavin Newsom he's going to run for
president he hasn't left anything in a
better State including a state I mean
look I mean look at Stanford I mean he
was mayor of San Francisco and that is
an
[Laughter]
I don't even know what that means I
don't even have the energy for an
artificial stance because I don't even
know what this me I mean he did fly his
husband to a rugby tournament didn't he
do that somewhere and well and also
remember they they made Tom Price quit
over here Tit for Tat I guess I'm all in
for that it's an artificial stance
they've done it to Republicans it's time
that they feel the wrath of
Investigations investigations across the
board televised live to be fair would
you let your husband go alone to a rugby
tournament no I I go by the Pence rule
uh and when my husband my husband only
can go with another man right uh to a
rugby tournament
I wanna Brian Kilmeade
a favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now